we've had four shocks to a lot of other
earthquakes the landers earthquake that
which is 7.3 two months earlier there
was a six point one called the Joshua
Tree earthquake that's a far enough
apart that we don't usually use the word
for shock we call it a free shock
there was a 3.8 a couple of hours before
the 7.3 in 1987 the superstition hills
earthquake 6.6 was preceded the day
before by a 6.2 so this is that's why we
keep on saying 1 in 20 chance well this
is the 20 by definition because the 7.1
is the largest we give it the name main
shock so yesterday or an hour ago we
were calling the 6.4 the main shock it
has now had an aftershock that's bigger
than itself and so we changed the name
and the 6.4 is now a 4 shock and that
really large aftershock has become the
main shock as far as we can tell those
names for shock main shock after shock
are semantic there are tools for trying
to describe what's going on but when you
have a sequence going on if every
earthquake makes another earthquake more
likely and that's what we're seeing
right here then you're already well
alright so just look right down here on
the lower part since the 7.1 we are only
seeing basically the force and 5 showing
up we've had 1 2 3 about 1000 5.7 okay
so we have an earthquake that's already
begun up north it's just slightly to the
north west of the main shock our early
warning system is saying 5.7 with 26
seconds till it gets here the one that's
was a 54.9 we felt so this assuming that
the magnitude isn't really miss
estimated my guests will be will feel
this as it comes through in about
the tune of aftershocks throughout the
rest of the evening well yes the largest
aftershock is likely to be a 6 at was
less than I saw I felt from the one that
was labeled all right so clearly we're a
long ways away from the earthquake we're
still should we feel it remember that
the people in Ridgecrest are going
through a lot worse than this we already
had damaged houses and structure fires
out of the first earthquake this is
going to have been more intense shaking
ok this came through just as a 3.5 well
yes the same fault system it does appear
to have multiple strands to it we've
already seen the two perpendicular ones
I think it got the the magnitude wrong
because yeah unless it hasn't come
through yet can you explain the
shakealert again because some people
just got the initial report that it
quote unquote wasn't working okay we
explained again that there that's what
the usgs handle that one yeah so yeah so
the system worked
yeah so the system the shake alert
system were both on the USGS side and on
the shaker berth la side the reason why
I'm alert your notifications didn't go
out to LA County is that the threshold
for shaking was set above what the
estimated shaking so it was just the way
that the system was designed and in fact
the same thing happened again tonight my
understanding the alerts do not go out
and on che guevara delay
the magnitude that was estimated with a
early warning system was 6.2 so the
initial magnitude estimate was too low
consequently the intensities were below
that threshold so the system is not
perfect but again what was experienced
here in Pasadena LA area these were not
damaging ground motions what's going on
up in Ridgecrest
those are gamma G ground motions so
those folks are really feeling it a
chance of another large quake like this
or even larger tonight
well it's dr. Jones had said there's a
there's a 5% chance that this could be
followed by an even larger quake well
the number of 5% is it usually for a few
days the most likely time is within a
day which is what of course we just saw
what 30 hours or something 36 hours yeah
sequence oh no I just don't remember one
that's had this in California that's had
that series there are places elsewhere
in the world there was a magnitude 8 and
a half that was a four shock to a nine
and a half in Chile so there is nothing
about the magnitude that says it can't
be a fortunate right but in California
one is in the seismicity of this state
you've never seen anything fun with 71
the takeaway here though is that as we
have just seen between yesterday and
today quakes that we say our main shocks
can't actually be four shocks to large
earthquakes so yeah yeah so it's the
epicenter is a little bit deeper
we do have geologists out in the field
we haven't got reports back but they'll
be able to go out and so that's the 10
miles right it's 10 miles down where is
the one yes
today was more like six or seven miles
down however a bigger earthquake also
involves a larger fault so it still may
very well I probably this is coming to
the surface what you're really worried
about is are we gonna trigger something
outside of this region right probably
not okay what because it's we're too far
away the ability to trigger another
earthquake is very spatially defined so
the most likely place to trigger it is
at the same look on the same fault as
you go away with distance it becomes
much less likely how far is that from
the San Andreas quite a ways we you know
it's not even on that figure it's a it's
over a hundred miles to the San Andreas
from from this location the Garlic fault
is a lot closer and the garlock fault is
another long fault if we were going to
be triggering something really big the
garlock might be a source for it this is
sort of like when landers happen near
the San Andreas and we said oh if we're
gonna set off something bigger there's
only the San Andreas around of course it
didn't happen but it was a possibility a
low probability possibility the garlock
luckily really runs through some of the
most isolated parts of California it's
the northwest part it's extended and
grown whereas the the north the south
west striking one you know doesn't seem
to have had more earthquake is that a
surprise at all to you that this whole
system was capable of this kind of earth
there's no there was a magnitude seven
and a half in 1872 in the Owens Valley
there have been lots of success there's
this whole series when I said Nevada
1915 in 1954 and I don't have the
magnitudes in my head this time but they
were sevens there were series of
earthquakes with several events within
them for six to seven in Mammoth in 1980
there were four magnitude six-and-a-half
that happened in one sequence over about
ten days this part of California is
characterized by these type of groups of
earthquakes that there might be a
several that end up larger the first one
is often not the big
one knowing that which one is the
biggest one means waiting till we see
that we aren't getting another one when
was the last time we had something
sizable on garlic not in the historic
record prehistoric that's an approximate
guess off of looking at these figures
which are having trouble coming up hope
that northwestern fault is that the one
that's moving into China that Southwest
striking one is the one that goes sort
of from China like down to Ridgecrest
the northwest is going up through the
China like maybe so I know that there
has been trouble trying to get you out
with just on to face have you guys made
any progress
yeah actually our geologists have
contacted the Navy and are able to get
on the base with some limited access now
that was prior to tonight's event so
presumably well I would expect that
there may be further damage on the naval
base we don't know yet I haven't gotten
reports but my suspicion is that the
geologists are going to be able to get
out there very quickly and look at
potential rupture the the other comment
here just following on what dr. Jones
was saying when we have events that
we're a main shock then becomes a
four-shot typically the triggering is
relatively close and that's actually
what we saw here these two earthquakes
are very relatively closely located so
the triggering typically does not happen
at a great distance more typically it's
close by I can't think of any example
where we've seen this type of force
shock triggering that isn't within just
a matter of a few kilometers I mean the
famous widespread one was Elmore
ranchman and superstition Hills a 6.2
that was on a Southwest striking fault
and then set off a 6.6 on a Northwest
striking fault sort of like this the
epicenter of my ranch was up here but
the fault extended right down to the
superstition hills and what we were
seeing
aftershocks pounding at the superstition
Hills fault
up until the time that the earthquake
happened the the main shock happened and
we've got a similar situation here
we had aftershocks along this fault we
had and then we had the 5.4 breaking
through a big turn to the northwest and
now we've had it again and we now see
more aftershocks up to the very North
West End and chances are we stopped now
it's possible that we'll continue to
extend up to the Northwest 7.1 magnitude
quake you could expect sequences over
here yes all right so it's the 7.3
Landers earthquake the last magnitude
five to that 1992 earthquake happened in
1998 so six years after the main shock
we should be expecting to record
earthquakes here for a long time can you
describe that terrain of where this well
the terrain is is is very isolated it's
desert not a lot of population so
actually in a sense for being able to
get people out there and look at it
there's a good opportunity and also
because it's not densely populated the
chance of having damage to structures
and injuries this is much lower but it
is still very you know it's hard rock
these are faults that are breaking
through hard rock that's why they create
these waves that we feel strongly even
down here so the blue means that
happened more than an hour ago but less
than 24 hours ago you can actually see
some yellow underneath because we're
more than 24 hours since the main
chocolate but all those blue dots are
the aftershocks over the last 24 hours
and that's the red ones are within the
last hours so the main shock has already
turned blue and that's right there the
mange the epicenter of the 6.4 was
basically at that corner and we think
ruptured well clearly ruptured to the
southwest probably also some ruptured at
the northwest in the same event maybe in
the aftershocks afterwards then the 5.4
aftershock was the one this morning was
located right in there moved to fault a
little fire
then we have the seven and now look at
that cluster up to the northwest we
think you know right now we we aren't
getting many of our aftershocks
recording yet the system is pretty
strung out and so pretty sure that that
is a continuous aftershock zones and
that would mean that's the extent of the
fault and this the length of the fault a
magnitude seven point one we would
expect that it's probably at least about
25 miles long and that would imply
probably that whole length from where
the 6.4 happened up to where those
aftershocks are up in the corner China
Lake up there this is red is yeah okay
yeah right the Naval airbase the Naval
Air Station is that whole area so this
is all within the Naval Air Station this
there's a fault
system so we see all these little faults
on the on the ground rather than naming
each little piece separately it's been
called the little lake fault system and
so that's right and if you look to look
at the mapping that we can see there and
we one of the things we can do if we got
a bit of a break and found some stuff we
can I will try to get out the state
geology map and really see the details
mapping that's been done in here
beforehand but notice that there's this
little string of you see where the the
cursors showing you all those little
faults going up to the northwest and
they it was not mapped as a through
going fault it was little pieces up
through here and now we have more little
pieces farther up so no we can't say oh
the faults used up but most likely if we
were to see more going on I would be
much I would think more likely that
we're heading to the northwest and
turning around and coming to the south
again the surface rupture they are the
thing like the epicenter is only the
place where the fault started to move it
is not the location of the earthquake
the earthquake happens over the whole
farm surface and just like if I were
going to try to take a tear this I can't
do this what I would do is I'd start a
tear here and then rip down this way and
that's this would be the epicenter this
would be the fault surface the
earthquakes happening over this whole
fault so we think that what's happening
here is a fault about 25 miles long we
started at the end the part that had be
broken before the seven-point-one
potentially it ruptured in both
directions about 80% of earthquakes are
unilateral rupture in one direction and
about 20% rupture in both directions
that's actually the left lateral one is
down on the north called the Southwest
striking falters so so down here and
it's not at all clear that that part has
moved in this in the 7.1 what do you
mean by kind of earthquake it's two
strikes with two strikes with it's
strike slip yeah that's something that
we can get from the seismic records and
it's very clearly strike-slip yeah and
and just to follow on with that the
event yesterday was left lateral
strike-slip
which actually released some compression
on what we think is the fault that
ruptured this evening and the 7.1 this
event presumably is a white lad in a
strike sling with but basically motion
horizontally and again with this
magnitude in this link the expectation
of having surface rupture is much much
greater and by being able to go out and
actually measure it they you know in a
7.1 I'm trying to think back for Landers
there was up to I don't know 10 feet of
displacement 18 feet was the match
meaning if the fault ran between you and
me right now we're looking at each other
after the earthquake I would be 18 feet
farther
yeah that's the school of thought a
while ago that the seismicity of the
state was moving straight out as opposed
to San Andreas and yet landers you had
Hector mine now you have this business
add to that academic right that debate
was not on human timescales that was
saying we were moving over there in the
next few million years but actually let
me let me turn that around a little bit
I think these events are a reminder that
we can have earthquakes anywhere in
Southern California you know it's and on
a human timeframe as dr. Jones is
explaining an event like today's could
occur in the LA basin it could occur
down south in the San Diego area that's
just because we live in an area that has
many many active phones right but if you
have an earthquake fault every click of
7.1 magnitude a hundred and fifty miles
away from the major metropolitan area
and you suffered damage here you're in
big trouble was there damage in the Los
Angeles area don't like my point is we
get calls oh and and there's a report of
a power outages somewhere the region has
to sustain a 7.10 absolutely okay and
and I think for the most part the region
has I think the incidences are probably
somewhat isolated I would I would be
very surprised if